it had everything that an olympic final
should
tension
tactics and the prayers of a nation back
home
in the tightest of games bruce marriott
took it to an extra end but the swedes
are world champions and they are led by
nicholas eden now the greatest curler of
all time they're absolutely gutted but
you know coming off the getting the
middle put around their neck and then
you know see the mesh in our phones and
uh
it's really comforting to see all that
support back home the metal looks pretty
good with our necks it's
it's yeah it's the wrong color but it's
silver and it's heavy and you know we're
we're all very very happy we are young
we're obviously looking to the future
and we want to be back here in four
years time so we're going to give it
everything we've got
at curl edinburgh where bruce mauitz
started aged 8 his other half could
barely watch
this has been a british dream since he
was 10.
so to get there
it's absolutely amazing
he's done so so well
he'll look back at him
however long it takes him a bit and
he'll be so proud of himself to
go there and achieve what he's done
so much goes into getting on a podium
but this team have earned their moment a
first olympic medal for each of them
win or lose i knew there was always
going to be tears this morning
everyone's so proud of the team here in
edinburgh all across scotland you saw
bruce there on the tv obviously they're
upset but you know they'll come back and
they're still a young team first medal
which is fantastic and we've got another
one to come
so curling is the way forward
and already this beguiling spectacle of
a sport is enjoying a surge of newcomers
scotland's curlers have rescued these
winter games for team gb after a series
of disappointments that silver medal is
now on the board and the women's curling
team goes next for gold
eve muharrad is at her fourth olympic
games her side face japan in the early
hours of sunday the final day of these
games
one last shot
at the elusive gold
tom parmenter sky news edinburgh